diligent leaders asks in terms of
platform social media is it better to
self brand or establish a name brand I
go back and forth diligent leaders
that's a solid question you know I think
it's something everybody struggles with
it you know
am I gonna be Gary Vaynerchuk on social
or am I gonna be like wine marketing man
look what happened there that's my
answer
what happens if you evolve a lot of
people watching right now started off as
marketing gurus but now cell you know
carrot juice one of the things I like
about being your name is that you can
evolve with it you're looking at a guy
who used to do a show where I drank wine
and spit into the bucket and now I'm
doing this show and I've a been able to
do a seamless transition because the
truth is many of us many of us have
different facets to our personalities
and so I am of the camp of going with
your name it's something that can stick
with you there's consistency you don't
have to rebrand I didn't have to change
my Twitter profile from wine guy to ask
you